left foot yes that really is 82 year old
oscar winner anthony hopkins doing
drake's tootsie slide
if you haven't seen him on social you're
missing out well because bob has been
regarded as a rather
dark actor i'm not that at all i'm the
opposite
you know i've had a great life i just
want to spread some
energy i do wish we could chat longer
but i'm having an old friend
for dinner we're just a few months away
from the 30th
anniversary can you believe that that's
right my gosh
30 years good evening oh yeah we want to
march down memory lane with you
before audiences even had a chance to
see silence of the lambs he's very witty
and very charming he's brilliant
so um and he does some very strange
things to people
a lot of hair but you've gone you know
buffalo bill's house is currently for
sale
in pennsylvania it rubs the lotion on
its skin or else it gets the hose again
could you ever live in that house it was
horrible place
who would buy that for now sir anthony
is on to a new passion
his fragrance candle and diffuser
collection the purpose of this brand was
something i've dreamed up in isolation
again
rooted in my commitment to the
partnership with
no kid hungry available this friday
every purchase provides up to 50 meals
to help
end childhood hunger what does sir
anthony hopkins smell like
oh well i can say what he smells like
delicious when i first met
tony the very first date and i went over
to his house he had candles and flowers
and diffusers and i walked in i thought
this man is perfect